tyler mcgill who was making his major
league debut today miguel has done great
in the minor leagues he's been really
the mets best minor league pitcher this
year at least in the high miners at 3 35
era he's been up 59 strikeouts in 40 and
two thirds innings between double a and
triple a so this will be an opportunity
and on the ground through the shift and
a base hit for freddie freeman that's
his first hit of the series
and we'll see mcgill pitch out of the
stretch
for the first time in the majors one on
one out
albies hits it out to left center
slicing over his pillar and that's the
second out freeman back the first two
away freeman runs the pitch reached four
and popped up near second base it was a
change up waiting on it is lendore he
makes the two-hand catch on the infield
grass right in front of the second base
bag and that retires the side so a nice
start for tylor mcgill kyle wright in
the miners in those eight starts uh
triple a gwyneth was two and six in his
starts
um he's a guy that has a big arm
fifth pick in the 2017 draft his best
start was last year here in september
sixth in the third one hit ball here's
conforto who last played on the 16th of
may in tampa bay for his hamstring that
night missed 34 games
and michael drives one down the right
field line that'll go into the corner
lindor on his way to third adrianza
fields it they'll stop lindor at third
base conforto back in the lineup a
double his first time up boy that
reaction you can tell how excited he is
to be back
in the big leagues a mets team that has
not scored a run in the last 17 innings
second and third and one out with pete
alonso coming up now the pitch breaking
ball in the dirt skips to the back stop
here comes lindor he scores standing
without a throw conforto goes to third
mets take a one-to-nothing lead on a
wild pitch
and now runners are at the corners for
dom smith
tom grounds one on the
right side albies gets the force at
second as a run comes home and it's two
nothing new york
4-6 fielder's choice for the second out
dom gets an rbi his 28th
hit high in here to left but no carry to
it almante is under and after 31 pitches
kyle wright allows a pair to new york in
the opening inning of game four in
gotham and that'll bring up a ray in
brianza payoff pitch to adrianza
swinging a bouncing ball to first
waiting on it is alonso he's got it
crutched to the bag in time and there
are two men away
william contreras will be the better and
one and two to contreras mcgill deals
swung out and missed strike three side
retired and there is the first big
league strikeout
for tylor mcgill and to celebrate the
catcher james mccann
pumps his fist a little bit as mcgill
casually walks off the mound nothing
across middle of the second it's the
mets two and the braves nothing
one-on-one pitch guillerme lifts it in
the air to center pretty deep and see
arte going back at the track at the
fence he jumps and he can't hold on and
hit his glove drops right down in front
of him on the warning track and ciarte
picks it up and hurls it in on one hop
to third stopping at second and holding
there with a double is luis guiorme
and with two men away and guillerme
still at second back to the top of the
order and jeff mcneal
it's sharply toward the hole basic
around third george he'll come in to
score jeff mcneal finds a hole and
drives in a run and it's three-nothing
new york oh now francisco lindor of
course the mets would love to get going
2-0 pitch swinging to drive deep to
right he might have just done it there
it goes homer on franciscolandor
his ninth home run of the year and the
mets have a five to nothing second
inning lead
2-1 to alonso ground ball into the shift
backhanded by ozzy pops up sends one
over to freddy and there is out number
three
[Applause]
metz sent six to the plate in the first
inning they send seven to the plate in
the second inning
the one-two pitch
swinging to miss strike three tyler
mcgill gets his second strikeout the
slider or the cutter as they're calling
it here i guess that one was a slider
that put up slider for that pitch 3-2
pitch swinging a miss strike three
tylor mcgill
has retired eight in a row he has struck
out three it's a one two three third
we'll go to the bottom of the third
minutes five atlanta nothing josh tomlin
36 year old journeyman is on in long
relief for the braves i don't know how
many times we've seen tomlin have to
pick up the braves in these kind of
games
fly ball down the right field line back
toward the corner andreyanza goes over
his head and that is a fair ball off the
wall and mccann standing at second base
with a double and the 2-2
he finally got him and a couple of
strikeouts for mcgill
in tonight's action at the plate he
leads though five nothing pretty
freeman's on to begin the top of the
fourth one two
swinging a miss strike three a good
pitch by mcgill
slider on the back door as alby's swung
through it
chops softly toward first alonzo comes
in front of the bag to grab it takes it
to the base himself to retire riley and
the inning is over so tyler mcgill's
impressive debut continues in the
meantime here mcgill after that first
inning
jitters has really
pitched beautifully it's given up only
two hits both to freddie freeman that
brings up the number eight hitter ender
ncr tank two balls two strikes adrian's
a good lead to pitch
and ender unloads high in the air to
deep right did he keep it fair he did
ender hits one off the facade of the
second deck and the braves get back into
the game it's now a 5-2 score that was a
no doubt or ender knew it the crowd
saluting him as louise takes the ball
and mcgill gets a big ovation as he
walks off the mound
but a very credible debut for the 25
year old right-hander from long beach
california a brave at every base and
almonte coming up in a spot where they
got to throw strikes
chopper hit to mcneal he gets the force
side retired runner will move up riley
to third base with nobody out the 2-2
pitch
is on the ground lindor dives scrambles
fires and not in time infield hit it's
5-3 and the tying run comes to the plate
and the o2 from oswald swung on and
missed strike three side retired he got
him with a changeup
and there's a rocket up the middle
another base at frickin forta
michael on base for the third time in
his first game back and off the lefty
michael been struggling against lefties
earlier in the year that's have two on
nobody out here in the seventh
straw came out high fastball needed that
double play in order to get you out of
the inning one down again one for three
in this game with the double and mccann
finds the hole that's a base hit around
third conforto headed home in ciarte's
throw
and conforto scores and he tacks on a
run for new york it's six to three tying
run comes to the plate diaz has had one
five out save already this year
and it's in there for a call strike
three
and so sandoval down on strikes two men
away pitch swinging a high fly ball to
left not too deep drifting back mckinney
he's waiting he makes the one hand catch
and that retires the side the mets have
runners at the corners one out and
francisco lendore coming up
and that's walking in toward right
center over comes inciarte he'll have to
play it on a hop and that'll bring it a
run
guillerme comes in to score lendore with
his third rbi of the night and the mets
pad their lead to 7-3 well last call for
the braves are down four against edwin
diaz remember he came on in a save
situation in the eighth innings 3-2
ground ball lighter caught
alonzo snags it out of the air
and the mets win it